when you said like I wish we had more
time isn't that just so Universal for
when you love someone
and I know that death is an
inevitability another of us are escaping
it and
we don't know when it's coming and I
just think that the way that you help
people heal and how you see them the
specifics to people is just
unexplainable and incredible and
instills the faith in what you're doing
and I love how you put that well of the
universal I really because I think
people we have to stop looking at things
of
so black and white right yeah and just
accept and embrace the goodness and the
good things stop looking for the
negativity nothing comes good at a
negativity we can't have faith and fear
they don't mix